could Aliens destroy us from light years
away H another day at the kot Zak Labs
where we answer the most important
questions with science today how might
civilizations wage war across light
years what kind of devastating weapons
could they use and what would they look
like meet our two players a yellow dwarf
star system home to a species of
primates humans as they call themselves
recently became a technological
civilization they have Rockets nuclear
reactors and memes how
cute the Scorpions
disagree they reside on a planet around
the orange dwarf star HD
4307 42 light years away scorpion
civilization developed earlier than
humans and they have much better
technology they've recently built a
Dyson swarm around their star which
gives them near Limitless energy and
they noticed Humanity which is
unfortunate as the sorion are planning a
high hyperspace bypass through our solar
system so they decided that Humanity has
to go Interstellar war is hard though
front lines tactics and Logistics are
meaningless at these scales it's also
fought across time decades will pass
between firing a weapon and learning
whether it hit or not sending an
invasion Fleet is futile even if the
Scorpions travel at a large fraction of
the speed of light the journey to Earth
would take decades or even centuries and
hum would have plenty of time to prepare
if you want to learn more about the
mind-numbing problem of war between
alien civilizations we made a video
about it today we'll help the sorion
construct a weapon that is not only
extremely long range and as fast as
physically possible but that will
totally destroy everything on Earth so
no human survivors will come to enact
Vengeance on Sor in the future in
interstellar War you want to win with
one shot our bird scientists have found
three sorion designs the star laser the
relativistic missile and the ultra
relativistic Electron Beam all based on
real technologies that humans are using
in some form already let's see how they
work the star laser as an advanced
technological civilization the Scorpions
harness the energy of their Star by
surrounding it with billions of solar
power satellites this Dyson swarm
collects 1% of the star's energy output
a million billion billion Watts 50
billion times more than all Humanity
generates what if all the power of the
Dyson swarm all those satellites were
used to create a star laser like any
laser the bigger it is the longer its
range human built lasers use small
mirrors to focus so they have short
ranges the sorion could turn their
entire Dyson swarm into a collective
focusing element a million km wide the
star laser has an insane range as the
result enough to focus on target Earth
from a distance of over 2 million light
years okay let's shoot
it countless tiny beams combine into a
single huge beam laser beams are
normally invisible in space but the star
laser is so powerful that light
scattering off bits of dust and gas in
its path makes it clearly visible in the
sky a gigantic column of green light the
laser travels at the speed of light
which oddly enough is still pretty slow
on a galactic level it takes a whole day
until the laser has left the sorion
system shooting into the emptiness
between Stars it will travel for decades
occasionally melting the odd bit of
Interstellar dust or
asteroid 42 years after being fired it
arrives without warning humans only
notice a weird green glow in the sky and
then they're gone 1% of the energy of a
star concentrated into a beam the
diameter of Earth traveling 42 light
years it burns the exposed half of the
planet with the intensity of 3 million
Suns the Seas boil and evaporate fires
scour the land and within minutes
Earth's crust begins to melt into a sea
of lava as the planet rotates it turns
into a red hot hell with no trace of
life after a day it's all over and the
laser dies down in another 42 years the
Scorpion will know if they've been
successful that's another thing about
Interstellar War when you attack your
grandchildren will be the ones to find
out if you won it's like the bombs from
World War II exploding in the 80s and us
only seeing the effect today okay the
star lasers extreme range speed of light
attack and ability to melt down any
Target make it a premier Interstellar
weapon but is there something
else the relativistic
missile What If instead of converting
the energy of their Dyson swarm into a
laser the Scorpions used it to shoot a
super bullet a relativistic missile
going as close to the speed of light as
possible this sort of weapon is at the
limits of what the sorion technology can
handle as it requires loads of a highly
dangerous material antimatter the evil
twin of regular matter humans have only
managed to produce a few nanograms of
antimatter with their unlimited energy
scorpions can manufacture it at an
industrial scale to build antimatter
Rockets when antimatter and matter are
mixed they annihilate which in more
practical terms means there's a big big
boom releasing gamma rays and plasma the
physics is complicated but basically if
you have a really strong magnetic field
you can deflect the plasma through a
nozzle just like in the chemical Rockets
humans use but it would be much much
faster the fastest rocket possibly
basically our relativistic missile is
much bigger than a
skyscraper at the bottom is the
bell-shaped magnetic nozzle 100 m wide
on top of it are 250 floors filled with
antimatter and M L ready to annihilate
each other on the top floor is a 300 kg
projectile looking quite small about the
size of a person to stop them getting
damaged on the way the missiles have
dozens of sacrificial layers that form a
Whipple Shield to make sure they do
their job the Scorpions build 1,000
missiles let's fire them launching all
the relativistic missiles is a
spectacular event for a moment the
antimatter engines lighting up outshine
their star there is exhaust is a long
trail of brilliant white and as they
accelerate away they appear redder and
redder until they turn invisible with
the extreme amount of energy released by
the matter antimatter reactions the
missiles are accelerated to
99.999999 6% of the speed of light they
have effectively infinite range as
there's nothing really to slow them down
they arrive shortly after you can see
them the light from their launch will
take 42 years to reach Earth so human
astronomers might see the flash of the
missile's launch and then a few days
later they'll hit not enough time to
prepare each relativistic missile packs
the kinetic energy of a dinosaur killer
asteroid so only one needs to hit they
never reach the ground disintegrating
Instead at the edge of Earth's
atmosphere intense blue flashes set
everything on fire then continent sized
Fireballs Slamm down on the surface to
smash everything into dust repeatedly
until nothing is left but rubble and
smoke so Interstellar missiles with
unlimited range minimal warning and
delivering complete destruction of a
planet's surface nice but they are a
hassle to build is there something else
maybe the ultra relativistic Electron
Beam humans do funny things to their
food to rid it of bacteria and make it
safe to eat like shooting electron beams
at strawberries small particle
accelerators send electrons into the
food with with an energy similar to the
radiation from nuclear reactions not
enough to burn the food but deadly to
bacteria sorion had the same idea but
bigger the main challenge with an
electron beam is range electrons are
negatively charged particles so they
don't want to stay near each other a
regular Electron Beam will quickly
spread out making it harmless scorpions
need it to cover distances of dozens of
light years so they've used the rules of
the universe to trick the electrons by
building an Ultra relativistic Electron
Beam or Europe what it does is
accelerate the electrons to
99.99999
9999999999
99999 98% of the speed of
light faster than even the most powerful
cosmic rays the closest something
travels to the speed of light the slower
time moves for it relative to the rest
of the universe and since these
electrons are moving so incredibly fast
for every second of spreading their
experience over 5 million years pass in
real time a physics trick that lets the
beam cross Interstellar distances while
remaining tightly focused on its Target
the biggest particle accelerator on
Earth is 27 km long the Scorpions need
one that's over 100,000 km long a mega
structure 8 times longer than Earth is
wide it's mostly a tube of magnets
holding the beam together until the exit
like a long trumpet of Doom surrounded
by an aura of deadly radiation when it's
fired it produces a ruler straight
lightning bolt pointed at Earth its
effects on a rival are less visible than
the other weapons no flashes of light no
massive firestorms no explosions it
doesn't destroy rocks it destroys DNA
people get dizzy Then Fall sick as their
cells are pierced by radiation you might
think that a deep bunker could save a
few humans but no
the urb is so penetrating that its
effects accumulate to lethal doses even
underground over days or weeks in the
end just like our strawberries Earth
becomes
sterile simulation results H another
elaborate animated science explainer by
kotart where we've learned a lot not
sure exactly what luckily the Scorpions
don't really exist but others might one
major downside of all our weapons is
that others around the Milky Way could
see you firing them which is not ideal
because you don't want to present
yourself as a dangerous species and tell
everybody where exactly you are so maybe
instead of shouting or shooting out into
the universe the best course of action
seems to be to stay relatively quiet for
now and observe maybe one day we'll
witness distant Stars shooting at each
other and be glad we stayed out of
it but we don't have to stay out of
Intergalactic fun there's a peaceful way
to join type 2 civilizations on their
Galactic Adventures look it's the
galactic Club a Cozy Corner in the vast
Universe reserved for friendly quirky
folk like you come in and don't worry
we've got everything you need to fit
right in it's all part of our latest
limited drop kill your alien friends
with kindness and impress them with
these colorful patches and sweaters wear
these new iconic t-shirts that represent
your love of stargazing and show
allegiance to our ultimate over de and
the star of the show a woven space
blanket to wrap yourself and your new
alien buddies in maybe the coolest thing
we've ever created definitely the
largest like with our last limited Rob
these items are available now until they
sell out and then never again pair them
up with the 1224 Cosmic Creations
calendar to have a beautiful daily
reminder of potential alien
civilizations and a way to make plans
with all your new Pals all of our
products are designed and produced with
love and care by us here at kot zags
they are an integral part of the science
story we try to tell so start your
journey on our Channel and continue it
with our posters calendars and plushes
every purchase directly funds what we do
on this channel thank you so much for
your support join the galactic club now
Overlord duck is
[Music]
waiting